[Music]
going into season three what's your
number one question you want to answer
Wow number one question I want answered
I feel like my number one question for
season three is how the hell did we end
up here
Society has sort of lost lost touch lost
hold of where we were so how did we get
here and how do we get out of it
we still have Oprah though isn't that
awesome
Oprah man um she she seems to be a fan
of the show and yeah yeah there's
there's a little Easter egg in there
broadcasting from somewhere in the great
white north hopefully we can get her on
screen maybe a camera next season oh
that would be that would be totally fine
with me I don't think we would eject
Samira certainly doesn't object Hey Girl
hey my question for season three is who
is Oprah and is she my mom is she my
sister is she my sister in season four
yeah can we get more than her voice
can't get her on camera her and I
starting a revolution season four yes
that's season three thank you you and
Oprah thank you you know crack
was this an American patriot or gilead
traitor we are still here Stars and
Stripes forever baby
[Music]
the Cameo heard round the world Oprah
could we expect to see Oprah in season
three
well we haven't talked about that yet
who knows I mean it's it's interesting
and I think we have a good feeling not
only when we hear Oprah's voice of
course but the notion that that's out
there at that Radio Free America that
there's a pulse still left for values of
America so who knows you know that could
maybe continue fans think Oprah is more
than just a radio host what we could do
worse and having over as the president
of America well we'll see
[Music]